Hi, welcome to Recitation. My name is Martina and I'll be your Recitation Instructor for
some of these linear algebra videos. Today's problem is a straightforward solve the following
linear system with four equations and four unknowns using the method of elimination.
The system is x minus y minus z plus u equals 0, 2x plus 2z equals 8, minus y minus 2z equals
minus 8, and 3x minus 3y minus 2z plus 4u equals 7. And although you might know different
ways to solve this system at this point, the method of elimination is going to show up
a million times during these videos, so it's really important to get it right. So I suggest
you try solving this system now using the method of elimination as it was described in
class. I'm going to leave you alone with the problem. You should pause the video, solve
it yourself, and then come back and compare your solution with mine. And we're back.
So the method of elimination, if you remember it from class, consisted of replacing this
system with an equivalent system, equivalent meaning they have the same solution, by a
series of row operations. Row operations are not supposed to change the solution to
the system, and therefore, for example, exchange the order of two equations. Multiply an equation
with a nonzero number and add a nonzero multiple of one equation to the other. So let's do
that. As we're going to do this series of arithmetic operations, we don't really want
to copy the names of the variables and the equality signs every time, so we're going
to keep the important information which are these numbers, these coefficients here, we're
going to keep that information in a matrix. So let's write a matrix. Each row is going
to correspond to an equation, and each column is going to correspond to an unknown. So the
first row is one minus one minus one one. The second row corresponding to the second
equation is two zero two zero. And you want to be very careful to put zeros on the right
spots here. The third equation is zero minus one minus two zero, and the fourth row corresponding
to the fourth equation is three minus three minus two four. And as we care about the right
hand side as well, we're going to copy this information as well and get the augmented
matrix of the system. Zero eight minus eight seven. Okay, and now let's try reducing this
matrix to an upper triangular one. We start with the first column and we're going to use
this number called the pivot to get rid of all the numbers under it. So to get zeros here
and here. A way to do it is, well, to get rid of this two, I have to multiply the first
row by minus two and add it to the second one. This is not, writing this here is not
strictly necessary, but I like to do a bit of bookkeeping because I'm prone to make a
lot of errors while doing these simple arithmetic operations. And then if I get to the end,
figure out I made a mistake somewhere. This bookkeeping makes it easier to backtrack and
find the place where I made this mistake. So we replace this matrix with another matrix. The
first row stays the same. One minus one minus one one zero. The second row gets replaced by a
second row minus two times the first row. The aim of that is to get a zero here. So that's
good. Next on this position here, we get minus two times minus one, which is two plus zero,
which is two. Minus one times minus two, which is two plus two, which is four. Minus two plus zero,
which is minus two. And eight minus two times zero, which is eight. The third row already has a zero
here, so I can just copy it over. Zero minus one minus two zero minus eight. And to get a zero
here, I'm going to multiply the first row by minus three and add it to the fourth row and get zero
minus three times minus one is three, minus three is zero, minus three minus one, sorry, three minus
two is one, and minus three plus four is one. And there we go. The first column looks like a first
column of an upper triangular matrix. Now let's do the same to the second column. This is going to be
our pivot, the number that we use to get rid of numbers under it, and we see that to get rid of
this number here, we will need to multiply it with one half. So multiply the whole second row
with one half and add it to the third row. The matrix that we get will have the first row the same,
stays the same. One minus one minus one one zero. The second row stays the same. Zero, two, four,
minus two, eight. The third row gets replaced by the third row plus one half times the second row
and becomes zero, zero, two minus two which is zero, minus one plus zero which is minus one,
and four minus eight which is minus four. And the third row, the fourth row already has a zero
here so I just copy it over. Zero, zero, one, one, seven. And now let's look at this matrix. It has
the first two columns as they're supposed to be, zeros under the diagonal, and now we want to get a
zero here. Normally what I would do is to circle this number here, multiply it by something so that
I get a minus one, and add it to this row to get a zero here. But that's not going to work. You might
remember from lectures that zeros can never be pivots or you can just try finding a number such
that zero times this number equals minus one and seeing that such a number doesn't exist because
you're always going to get zero. So we cannot proceed as we did until now but is there another way
to get a zero here? There is a very simple row operation which consists just of switching the
third and the fourth row. It certainly doesn't change the solution of the system. So let's do that.
And let's get the next matrix which is one minus one minus one one zero. Zero, two, four, minus two,
eight. Then we put the fourth row here, zero, zero, one, one, seven, and we put the third row here,
zero, zero, zero, minus one, minus four.
And there it is. This is an upper triangular matrix. So in the same way as at the beginning we had a
system and then wrote the matrix representing it, this matrix also represents a system and this system
has the same solutions as the initial system but is much easier to solve. Now let me write this
back as a system and let me do that not starting from the first equation but starting from the
last equation. So the last equation here reads minus u equals minus four
which is as equations go a pretty easy one to solve. The solution is u equals four.
Now let's go back to the third equation. The third equation reads y, uh no I'm sorry z,
the third column corresponds to z plus u
equals seven. But we know what's u now. So it reads z plus four equals seven
which just becomes z equals three. The second equation is two times y
plus four times z but z is three minus two times u but u is four equals eight
and from this one can easily compute that y is equal to two. And finally the first equation reads
x minus y minus z plus u equals zero or x equals one. And this is our solution x, y, z and u
equal one, two, three and four. This finish is the problem but I would very strongly encourage
you now to take this solution and plug it back into the original system and check if it's really
a solution. And that's all I want you to say today.